die schuld ist erst mal beim virus ich
meine wir haben einen virus das neu auf
die welt gekommen ist eine jahrhundert
pandemie mit der wir gerade umgehen
müssen und das tragische leben vor allem
wenn das virus sich in eine
pflegeeinrichtung hinein wo ja auch
abstand schwer es so viele menschen auch
mit demenziellen erkrankungen sind wo er
viele auch im früher gesagt haben die
totale isolation dieses phasenweise
gegeben hat die hat auch viel einsamkeit
und leid verursacht haben sie empfunden
als gefängnis ohne gitter so ist das ja
von einigen beschrieben worden warum
soll ich foto kunz mistral sind schon
sehr sehr wichtig für uns heimat dass
wir einsehen
die herausforderung hier in dieser
pandemie das ist das virus und wir
müssen vermeiden dass das virus sich
ausbreiten und verbreitet das virus an
sich ist ja tot das kann sich alleine
nicht bewegen das bewegt sich durch uns
auch in eine pflegeeinrichtung aber wäre
es nicht an der zeit wenn sie jetzt den
fall in leverkusen sehen den angehörigen
nicht nur das beileid auszusprechen
sondern sich auch zu entschuldigen dass
deutschland so viel langsamer als
großbritannien usa israel und andere ist
wir haben uns sehr bewusst entschieden
für eine ordentliche zulassung der
tatsächlich drei vier wochen länger
gedauert als eine note zulassung ich bin
aber sicher dass wir das was wir auch an
zusätzlichem vertrauen durch das
zulassungsverfahren erhalten und
erhalten werden auf der strecke auch
auszahlt moment reden wir sehr viel über
knappheit und da verstehe ich auch die
ungeduld vor allem auch angesichts solch
tragischer beispiele wie sie gerade aus
leverkusen gebracht haben natürlich um
gleichzeitig werden wir eben auch in
eine situation kommen wo es um
impfbereitschaft geht weil um diese
pandemie unter kontrolle zu bekommen um
ausbrüche in pflegeeinrichtungen ganz
vermeiden zu können brauchen wir einen
sehr hohen anteil der bevölkerung der
sich impfen lässt
haben sie sich persönlich nichts
vorzuwerfen zuerst einmal jemand der ein
todesfall zu beklagen hat ein trauerfall
in der familie hat jedes recht sauer zu
sein verstehe ich auch gut
die frage ist ja was wann also habe ich
wider besseren wissens etwas nicht
entschieden oder entschieden nein wir
alle entscheidenden phasen von
unsicherheit in einer jahrhundert
situation in einer pandemie jeden tag
auf jeder ebene und müssen eben
dann immer wieder auch mit neuen
erkenntnissen natürlich entscheidungen
anpassen das ist seit beginn dieser
pandemie so das ist auch im moment so